dans ce contexte plus d'un million
d'ukrainiens ont fui le pays selon l'onu
ils se réfugient notamment vers les pays
voisins la hongrie la roumanie et la
moldavie
bonjour thomas ponte merci d'être avec
nous sur sur ce plateau
vous êtes me marié à une ukrainienne
vous êtes vous même de nationalité
ukrainienne depuis près d'un an corrigez
moi si je me trompe je suis pas
nationalité ukrainienne j'ai la carte de
séjour dako craignait ne pardonnez moi
vous étiez profession en tout cas
l'alliance française d'odessa c'est dans
le sud du pays le sud ouest sud ouest et
concrètement votre vie a bien sûr
basculé jeudi dernier il ya une semaine
premiers bombardements première
explosion racontez-nous comment vous
avez vécu ces heures avant d'évoquer
peut-être votre votre
votre fuite du pays comment est ce que
vous avez vécu ses premières heures de
guerre alors déjà on sentait venir mais
personne ne voulait y croire non c'était
vous pouvez pas du tout y croire donc le
jeudi matin vers 5 heures du matin j'ai
entendu une première explosion est assez
lointaine parce qu'on habite loin de
l'aéroport et ensuite j'ai entendu deux
autres explosions et là j'ai réveillé
mon épouse et on a pris un café les
premières à faire on est sortis dans la
rue et il n'y avait pas grand monde dans
la rue tout était plutôt calme on a
voulu se diriger vers la gare mais il y
avait un train qu'on voulait prendre
pour partir
à l'ouest vers la roumanie qui est qui
était déjà parti vous avez pris votre
décision fait aussitôt on s'était
quelques heures après les premières
explosions
vous avez pris cette décision voilà très
concrètes et rapides de fuir le pays en
fait vous s'était concerté avec mon
épouse j'ai pris la décision que s'il y
avait une ville n'importe quelle ville
qui était attaqué hors du dombass on
partirait vers la france donc on s'est
dirigés et finalement on a pris un but
ce qui nous a emmenés chez mes beaux
parents qui habitent dans la bessarabie
ukrainienne qui au sud qui traverse en
fait là il ya le fleuve le dies trop qui
est traversée pour le traverser on a
pris deux buts sont arrivés là bas ça
s'appelle belgorod nistre heures ce qui
est là en fait on a réfléchi on s'est
calmé un petit peu et puis j'ai reçu un
message de l'ambassade de france qui
demandait aux français de rester sur
place donc on a entendu un jour
jours odessa c'est encore calme mais ça
commence à péter un petit peu partout
donc là bas comme c'était très calme
dans bessarabie
il y avait possibilité d'aller à la
frontière moldave directement vers le
nord ce qui s'appelle pas lent car tout
maintenant tous les tout le monde et
connaît au dso cette frontière mais on
nous parlait des fois de 24 heures
d'attentes et finalement mon beau père
qui voulait rester avec ma belle mère
sont restés nous a déposé en voiture à
une autre frontière alors j'ai du mal à
le prononcer en ukrainien mais je crois
que c'est ce tollé cause aceh et là en
fait on a eu la chance y avait pas grand
monde et on a traversé une vingtaine de
minutes on arrive à un maul dhabi en
moldavie et de la moldavie vous avez
rejoint ensuite la roumanie on est là on
est resté une journée à chisinau et
ensuite après la moldavie à iasi et
ayachi ont été hébergés par une famille
on a pris l'avion pour beauvais le lundi
d'accord est arrivé lundi soir vous avez
j'imagine des amis des proches de la
famille ou belle famille peut-être à
odessa encore qu'est-ce que qu'elles
sont le qu'est-ce qui vous disent
traitement en fait c'est très étrange
parce qu'au dessin c'est très calme il
ya par les bombardements il est la
défense aérienne qui répond par aman il
ya des navires russes qui sont au large
mais la grande question c'est pourquoi
au dessin n'est pas attaqué c'est
quelque chose que je n'arrête pas d'y
penser d'y penser
il ya encore mon beau frère et ma belle
soeur y ait ses deux fils sont partis à
la campagne et la plupart des français
que je connais en tout cas au dessin son
parti et j'ai essentiellement des
collègues de l'alliance française des
ukrainiennes qui sont encore là-bas je
dirais une dizaine plus après toutes mes
connaissances puisque je joue au rugby
odessa aussi tous mes seins tous mes
potes d'odessa l'équipe de rugby sont
encore là bas vous êtes en contact avec
eux oui comment est ce qu'on vit sa de
j'imagine que l'éloignement la distance
doit est préférable sans doute ne doit
pas être facile non plus à gérer comment
est ce qu'on vise c'est à distance vous
êtes connecté en permanence sur sur ce
conflit ce qui se passe oui bien sûr
c'est surtout mon épouse aussi après moi
je suis plus les choses de manière un
petit peu géopolitique et de voir un
petit peu comment ça bouge parce que
beaucoup d'anxiété par rapport à la
suite des événements mais plus globale
c'est ce qu'on pourra retourner à odessa
un jour parce que c'est ça la grande
question aussi et en ukraine après je
pense outre aux autres villes
oui c'est ça après au niveau du travail
quand je vois aussi bête les ukrainiens
y en a plein qui ne peuvent plus
travailler aussi concrètement voilà
c'est un peu d'anxiété mais j'ai jamais
eu peur si je sais pas encore de la peur
d'accord je rebondis sur ce que vous
m'avez dit un petit peu plus tôt que
vous n'y croyez pas jusqu'aux premiers
bombardements pourtant on a l'impression
que rarement un conflit a été autant
annoncé pendant des semaines ou des mois
même par notamment les les autorités
américaines
ça a quand même été une surprise absolue
c'est à dire que malgré tout tous ces
bruits tous ces avertissements sur place
la majorité du peuple ukrainien ne
croyait pas à cette guerre
je dirais que c'est pas une surprise
c'est on voulait pas y croire on voulait
pas que ça arrive et après le peuple
ukrainien après je peux parler surtout
des dessins aude et ça c'est quand même
assez éloignée de la frontière donc tout
le monde se disait c'est bon on attend
de voir venir et voilà beaucoup il y
avait une espèce d'insouciance mais qui
existe depuis longtemps je pense après
j'ai jamais eu l'occasion d'aller dans
l'est de l'ukraine mais à kiev j'ai
jamais quand j'ai visité kiev il ya six
mois c'était plutôt calme aussi mais
c'était plus une habitude d'être dans un
pays avec la guerre avec toujours une
possibilité de conflit beaucoup plus
grand avec la russie
dernière question thomas ponte quand
vous voyez les images par exemple au
début de ce journal sur ce conflit
cette guerre à ce pays qui était libre
encore il ya une semaine et qui
maintenant a sombré dans dans dans ce
qu'on connaît qu'est-ce que comment vous
le vivez
quel est votre sentiment mais c'est un
désastre pour l'ukraine après je fais
pas faire de la géopolitique mais
concrètement je pense que l'ukraine va
être divisé d'une manière ou d'une autre
la vie sera plus du tout comme avant ça
c'est une certitude après moi juge je
connais l'ukraine depuis 2020 donc je
pense plutôt quand même à tous les gens
qu'on leur vie là bas mon épouse ma
famille là ma belle famille voilà ça
fait mal au coeur parce que
ce qui je dirais qu'on en tant que
français ça nous touche aussi parce que
l'ukraine c'est quand même un pays se
rendent compte c'est un pays qui est
quand même composé de plein plein de
communautés différentes entre les
russophones et ukrainophones les tatars
les arméniens et les géorgiens les
ukrainiens et c est une chose en tout
cas qui paraissait mai inimaginable il
ya encore même deux semaines c'est tout
le peuple ukrainien est soudé hormis
peut-être encore certains extrémistes
mais il ya des personnes qui étaient
encore plus ou moins quand on parlait
quand on discutait ou des sacs etc
russophone quand même comme ville qui
est toujours plus ou moins une oreille à
droite une oreille à gauche et là
sincèrement je pense que la plupart des
ukrainiens maintenant se sentent
complètement crise ou des mercis tom